[Musique]
vous êtes bien sûr territoire Val de
Loire c'est l'heure de votre JT ce soir
c'est une édition spéciale que nous vous
proposons nous allons revenir sur les
différents débordements qui ont eu lieu
cette nuit encore suite à la mort de
Naël à Nanterre il y a trois jours et
pour comprendre et analyser ces
phénomènes plusieurs invités à mes côtés
Guillaume Saint-Cricq bonjour vous êtes
donc le secrétaire adjoint de la
préfecture d'Indre-et-Loire face à vous
Charles Fournier merci également d'être
venu vous êtes le député de la première
circonscription d'Indre-et-Loire bonsoir
et enfin Michael Texier vous êtes le
rédacteur en chef de Tv Tours Val de
Loire bonsoir tout au long de cette
émission nous allons donc revenir sur
cette nouvelle nuit de violence en
Touraine sans 141 sapeurs-pompiers ont
été mobilisés déployés sur la métropole
tourangelle dans la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi 800 appels au 18 ou au 112 ont
été comptabilisés par les services du
zit du 10 37 qui sont intervenus sur une
quarant de départ de feu 31 voitures et
deux bus ont été incendiés des commerces
ont été pillés en réaction un couvre-feu
pour les mineurs a été décrété à partir
de ce soir et ce dans toute la métropole
tourangère ainsi qu'à en boîte de 22h à
6h du matin une décision prise par le
préfet d'Indre-et-Loire on l'écoute
c'est une mesure d'interdiction
des mineurs à partir de 22h jusqu'à 6h
du matin
sur l'ensemble des communes qui ont été
touchées cette nuit sur donc les quatre
communes de la métropole et sur la ville
d'Amboise près du tiers des personnes
que nous avons interpellé cette nuit en
train de piller un magasin à Tours
étaient des mineurs voilà et au niveau
national ce chiffre est confirmé un
tiers des 900 personnes interpellées en
France sont des mineurs
attendant et dans le quartier du beffroi
une auto-école et un supermarché ont
notamment été prise à partie sur place
les habitants ne comprennent pas ces
déferlement de violence Aurélie Renaud
à minuit des dizaines de personnes s'en
prennent au supermarché près du beffroi
les propriétaires tentent de joindre la
police en vain les pompiers sont pris à
partie et font demi-tour alors les deux
directeurs du magasin et quelques
riverains vont eux-mêmes éteindre les
rayons incendiés la crainte un incendie
généralisé de l'enseigne qui se trouve à
proximité d'une station-service parmi
les pilleurs des hommes déguisés en
policiers municipaux car quelques
minutes plus tôt c'est le poste de
police municipale du beffroi qui a été
dégradé et pillée pour les habitants
c'est l'exaspération donc
c'est un peu une révolte pour rien quoi
tout péter je pense que ça vous tient
sens en fait par exemple
des leaders
[Musique]
casser les choses des gens parce que les
gens ils se réveillent le matin ils
trouvent pas leur voiture les dégâts
matériels sont lourds au beffroi
l'entrée de la mairie annexe et celle de
la médiathèque ont été saccagés tous les
abribus du quartier sont cassés et
plusieurs voitures ont été brûlées le
patron de l'auto-école voisine a perdu
deux véhicules
à la gendarmerie porter plainte après
j'ai j'ai appelé le dépanneur et puis là
je m'occupe de remplacer les véhicules
ça m'a demandé du temps voilà
faire d'activité assez conséquente dans
le magasin d'optique plus une paire de
lunettes au bureau de tabac le rideau de
fer est éventré toute la journée les
services municipaux ont tenté d'effacer
les stigmates de cette nuit de violence
on l'a vu beaucoup de dégâts à tournera
déplorer notamment mais également des
blessés du côté des forces de l'ordre
de police
dans le cas de l'exercice de leur
fonction
son caractère de gravité mais ce sont
des projectiles et
une question de mortier qui était très
importante pendant cette nuit des meute
on nous rappelez combien de policiers de
gendarmes déployés durant la nuit
dernière alors des objectifs qui ont
doublé par rapport aux effectifs normaux
puisque on avait autour de 139 policiers
beaucoup aidé par les militaires qui
étaient présents voilà et cette nuit
cette effective va encore augmenter avec
l'arrivée d'unité du été mobile
875 personnes ont été interpellées dans
la nuit de jeudi à vendredi en France en
Indre-et-Loire est-ce que vous avez les
derniers chiffres sont 13 personnes
interpellés
voilà donc des enquêtes sont en cours
évidemment je peux pas mais m'exprimer
sur sur ces enquêtes voilà donc des
profils particuliers qui changent de ce
dont on pose ce à quoi on pouvait
s'attendre
des jeunes de quartiers évidemment ce
qui nous interroge c'est l'éventuelle
éruption de personnes extérieures à ces
quartiers bon pour l'instant ce sont des
éléments qui sont soumis à l'enquête ça
des éléments plutôt radicalisés style
Black Bloc c'est en tout cas ce que
certains habitants aussi ont déclaré
notamment les médiateurs ou vous savez
les coordinateurs de centre de vie
sociale qui ont qui connaissent très
bien leur jeûne et qui ont découvert des
personnalités des personnes extérieures
au quartier et des groupes de jeunes
femmes si je ne m'abuse c'est nouveau en
effet c'est quelque chose qui a surpris
des groupes de jeunes femmes étaient en
effet présente alors moi je dirais
qu'elles sont minoritaires par rapport
aux jeunes aux jeunes hommes mais en
effet des groupes de jeunes femmes
étaient présentes c'est une première en
général et on n'a pas de jeunes femmes
dans ce jeune fille dans ce genre de
matière c'est en tout cas pour
casser nouveau pour assez inédit en tout
cas c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on constate
voilà
plutôt jeune l'âge c'est plutôt je peux
pas vous dire parce que ils ont pas été
interpellés mais en effet c'est
peut-être quelque chose de nouveau
la première circonscription de Tours et
les différents quartiers qui qui
composent la ville comment s'est passé
j'allais dire votre journée et votre
soirée qui a précédé alors la soirée qui
a précédé j'étais évidemment en veille
et en écoute de ceux qui pouvait se
passer dans dans les quartiers de Tours
en particulier mais il y aura aussi
puisque je suis un député de la nation
et puis
vouloir essayer d'expliquer c'est la
sensible riz non moi je crois que nous
avons la responsabilité d'essayer de
comprendre d'agir d'apporter des
réponses et si nous ne le faisons pas la
situation peut se dégrader encore plus
ce vendredi matin il restait encore des
marques des débordements qui ont eu lieu
dans le quartier du Sanitas ces places
de la liberté à Tours car de tourisme et
véhicules incendié magasin pillés tour
d'horizon d'une nuit de violence avec
Clémence dosc
c'est la sidération en cette fin de
matinée nous sommes à côté de la place
de la Liberté au niveau du magasin Lidl
le magasin a été pillé cette nuit il y a
également eu plusieurs voitures brûlées
juste devant et le feu s'est propagé
jusqu'aux arbres il y a beaucoup de
passants justement qui s'arrêtent devant
le magasin pour prendre des photos pour
discuter beaucoup sont en état de choc
en fait et se rendre compte que les
courses ça va pas être possible
aujourd'hui et se dirige donc vers le
marché on a discuté aussi également avec
quelques habitants de habitants
majoritairement des personnes âgées qui
ont vu tout ce qui s'est passé qui ont
vu les flammes et qui ont eu peur le
bruit des explosions des
artifices des pétards de toutes sortes
il écrit des hurlements enfin tout je me
rends chez ma maman je suis très
inquiète bah j'étais vraiment très très
horrifié de voir que son immeuble aurait
pu brûler j'ai de la famille dans
l'immeuble des deux personnes dont une
qui a 90 ans qui était complètement
terrorisée qui a pour essayer elles ont
essayé d'appeler les pompiers la police
il y a eu il s'est passé deux heures
avant que qui que ce soit intervienne
dérivera impuissants face au spectacle
de cette nuit relayée sur les réseaux
sociaux des images du pillage du magasin
matériel électronique mais aussi de
nombreux produits de première nécessité
et alimentaires ont été emportés dans la
nuit pétard et feu d'artifice résonnés
sur la place plusieurs véhicules ont été
incendiés comme ce camion et ce bus
touristique allemand les pompiers
terminés d'éteindre le feu ce matin
juste à côté de la discothèque avenue
Grammont d'autres voitures quasi
réduites ensemble une des propriétaires
étudiantes étaient en soirée lors des
incidents à partir du moment où ça
commençait à péter devant le PIMS et ben
on nous a dit restez calme et puis il se
passe quelque chose dehors donc on s'est
posé des questions et au moment où ça
s'est un peu apaisé on a pu voir les
caméras et là se rendre compte que
quelques voitures avaient cramé dont la
mienne donc là aujourd'hui je viens voir
s'il reste quelques petits trucs j'ai pu
récupérer malgré tout des clés mais
voilà il reste plus rien pour l'instant
l'heure est au rangement et à la
constatation des dégâts les habitants
choqués appréhendent la prochaine nuit
Charles Fournier derrière le saccage de
ce supermarché la place de la Liberté
alors on l'entend il y a la colère de la
jeunesse mais vous l'avez dit est-ce
qu'il y a pas derrière aussi un problème
d'inflation et une fracture sociale qui
est sous-jacente bien évidemment il y a
ça après quand on regarde sur les
différentes générations des meutres on a
toujours eu comme cible les services
publics finalement c'est une manière un
peu de se retourner l'arme contre soi
mais c'est parce qu'on comptait sur les
services publics pour l'intégration et
quand elle n'a pas fonctionné évidemment
bah c'est la cible et puis la plupart
pourrait s'en prendre à leur patron mais
faudrait-il qu'ils aient un patron
beaucoup ne travaillent pas n'ont pas
cette situation donc les institutions et
l'idole d'une certaine manière c'est une
forme de service public alimentaire par
défaut puisque on accède à
l'alimentation qui ne coûte pas cher et
donc on s'en prend à ça et puis bien
évidemment il y a des sujets d'inflation
mais je voudrais tout à l'heure quand je
disais il faut revenir à un ordre c'est
ça qu'il faut travailler il faut revenir
un ordre républicain d'égalité de
liberté et c'est pas des communiqués de
presse je sais pas si vous l'avez lu le
communiqué de presse de l'INS la police
et Alliance police ce jour même
hallucinant qui appelle à quasiment un
coup d'État qui parle de vermine qui
parle qui emploie des mots absolument
insupportables comme tout le monde
essaye d'appeler un retour de
l'apaisement ça ce n'est pas possible
bien vrai enjeux entre police et
population il faut ses spécifique à la
France ça ne se passe pas dans d'autres
pays regardez en Allemagne en disant un
seul refus d'obtempérer qui s'est
traduit par un mort nous c'est un par
mois depuis un an et demi donc il faut
revenir là-dessus il faut travailler
cette relation elle est fondamentale et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui elle ne va pas
il y a des éléments à l'intérieur de la
police il y a évidemment des éléments à
l'intérieur de la vie des quartiers mais
il faut retravailler ces questions sinon
on continuera d'avoir ces affrontements
et dans ces manifestations on s'en prend
à Lidl mais on s'en prend aussi à la
police et il y a quelque chose derrière
qu'il faut absolument travailler alors
là on est sur du temps long sur du temps
court genre je retourne vers vous
Guillaume saint-cric quel renfort pour
les jours à venir vous avez commencé à
l'aborder combien d'hommes en plus
qui devrait évidemment augmenter présent
sur le terrain le but c'est d'être
présent sur le terrain vous avez
constaté que c'est très disséminé
puisqu'on a 10 quartiers politiques de
la vie enfin 12 et 3 quartiers de
reconquête républicaine donc en fait la
difficulté ça dissémination des émeutes
et la grande difficulté c'est pour ça
que les les citoyens sont pleins de du
temps
lié à ça évidemment
c'est de ne pas saturer c'est que quand
vous avez donné un signalement une
voiture qui brûle
inutile
inutile de rappeler ensuite c'est du
temps perdu les les pompiers prennent
l'appel ils vont gérer mais il fallait
hiérarchiser les priorités et vous savez
que les fonctions de plus aujourd'hui
doivent accompagner également les
pompiers sur leurs interventions ce qui
était sécurisé évidemment donc c'est un
temps perdu qui qui est important donc
voilà il y a eu des voitures beaucoup de
voitures qui ont voulu d'une trentaine
des bâtiments évidemment les pompiers
doivent intervenir en toute sécurité et
donc on perd on l'a perdu du temps des
commerces aussi et la règle c'est quand
même de d'abord sécuriser les bâtiments
publics les bâtiments de l'État et des
communes
à certains bâtiments d'habitation
évidemment c'est les bâtiments et les
bâtiments publics mais les bâtiments
usage d'habitation ça me permettent on
paye là aussi des années de réduction
des moyens dans les forces de l'ordre
sous Nicolas Sarkozy moins 40 000 postes
qui ont été supprimés des postes de
travailleurs sociaux c'est aussi
malheureusement la résistante on voit
bien la difficulté à mobiliser des
forces de l'ordre quand partout ça
s'embrasse et je peux vous dire quand on
est à la route on se demande si autour
va être prioritaire si
Saint-Pierre-des-Corps va l'être il y a
un vrai sujet de capacité là aussi on a
supprimé les polices de proximité qui
étaient un moyen d'entretenir une forme
de relation plus constructive avec une
difficulté pour le coup c'est que quand
ça il y a des émeutes dans une ville en
France
fort viennent d'autres villes là il y a
des modes partout exactement chacun doit
faire avec ses propres moyens c'est ce
que rappeler préfet on conférence de
presse tout à l'heure justement Michael
ce vendredi après-midi un point presse
avait lieu
en prêt que les différents mères
concernés par ces violences urbaines
objectifs faire le point sur les mesures
à prendre dans les jours à venir que ce
soit à tour jouer les tours la riche
Saint-Pierre-des-Corps Saint-Cyr ou même
en Boisse les appels au calme se
multiplient Mickaël vous avez donc
assisté à cette réunion que faut-il en
retenir alors cette conférence de presse
suivez effectivement une réunion qui
précisait vous l'avez rappelé un
dispositif de sécurité pour la nuit et
le week-end à venir c'était aussi le nom
du préfet de manière de mettre en avant
les mères des communes les plus touchées
en fait on vous les avez cités
Saint-Pierre je les tours la riche en
bois tours chacun démarre présent avec
on le voyait elle est très du visage
tiré par deux nuits agitées
ils exprimaient l'espoir que les moyens
mis à disposition en fait j'allais dire
de la population pour être sécurisé
serait suffisant un espoir mais pas une
certitude car ils sont tous inquiets
pour les nuits à venir et mieux devenir
rappeler d'ailleurs et vous l'avez dit
on l'a vu dans les différents sujets que
une partie de la population avait pu
avoir le sentiment d'être abandonné
qu'en policier et pompier était occupé
ailleurs c'est aussi l'occasion de
dresser le bilan des dégradations dans
chacune des communes le centre
commercial de Joué-lès-Tours incendié un
super u à tour on l'a vu à
Saint-Pierre-des-Corps une ancienne
salle municipale un entrepôt un gymnase
un espace intercommunal les mers les
mairies de la riche jouer Saint-Pierre
sauvé c'est les mots qui ont été
utilisés par l'intervention des pompiers
et des forces de l'ordre
Saint-Pierre-des-Corps ou le maire a vu
sa voiture incendiée cette nuit
invectiver par les jeunes autour de lui
et on le voit sur ces images un moment
très forte tension vécu par Emmanuel
François email François qui considère
que lors de cet épisode malgré tout à
aucun moment il n'a senti de danger pour
son intégrité physique je vous propose
de l'écouter
il y a eu des insultes effectivement qui
visait le maire mais il n'y a pas eu une
volonté de me nuire
physiquement bien sûr certains étaient
plutôt véhément que d'autres mais dans
dans l'ensemble finalement avec ceux qui
sont moins véhément et qui ne veulent
surtout pas que des débordements
physiques et finalement j'ai pu échapper
au pire oui ça a été dur ça a été dur
oui je pense que il sera nécessaire de
porter plainte ne serait-ce que pour
notifier dans dans au commissariat ce
qui s'est déroulait comment ça s'est
déroulé pourquoi peut-être un jour on le
saura et pour Emmanuel François ce sont
les symboles qui étaient visés la
rappeler il a pris la parole pour son
début il voulait pas prendre la parole
lors de cette conférence de presse et
puis après que chacun des mères s'est
exprimé lui il a décidé de prendre la
parole pour dire ce ne sont pas les
personnes qui étaient visées ce sont les
symboles
l'espoir c'est que cela continue à
rajouter t-il et puis il a aussi eu
cette phrase indétrure le quartier où
l'on vit ce n'était pas peut-être pas la
meilleure réponse va apporter au décès
de Noël lui comme les autres mères
présents évidemment ont appelé au calme
à l'apaisement lui comme les autres
mères présents à remercier les forces de
l'ordre et les pompiers pour leur
intervention mais au-delà des forces
d'intervention d'intervention les
quartiers ont besoin de médiation et
c'est Emmanuel Denis le maire de tour
qui le rappelait en début de journée on
va redonner la consigne comme on l'avait
comment on l'a fait hier pour que les
dans les centres sociaux on puisse
organiser aussi des discussions enfin
que les craintes puissent s'exprimer
et donc la consigne c'est l'apaisement
appel au calme et puis il reste chez
vous ce soir
voilà une réunion avec les centres
sociaux médiateurs je crois avaient lieu
avec la préfecture aujourd'hui on en
attend beaucoup de ces médiateurs de
terrain c'est un lien fondamental parce
que ça se passe sur le terrain quand
même tout se passe sur le terrain donc
les médiateurs ont un rôle très très
important
ils sont vraiment ils connaissent leurs
jeunes ils sont sidérés aussi par les
médiateur c'est ce qui me disent et il y
a besoin d'espace de parole aussi donc
voilà il faut trouver maintenant d'un
maire de communiquer d'atteindre ces
jeunes et ce qui disent c'est qu'en
effet c'est que ces jeunes là sont quand
même très très compliqués d'une part
parce qu'il y a une défiance aussi
vis-à-vis des institutions disons-le
clairement donc la question serait
comment on arrive à voilà les atteindre
et avoir un discours qui qui fait sens
après en effet je suis d'accord avec ce
qu'il faut absolument que les jeunes se
soient restent chez eux
c'est fondamental et c'est pour ça qu'on
a réuni les les voilà
les ces médiateurs on va peut-être
organiser des
des réunions ou des événements comme
tout touche pas à ton quartier qui va se
faire pour sensibiliser et trouver un
espace de parole pour tout le monde
Charles Fournier que peut faire le
gouvernement pour apaiser la colère le
policier a été mis en examen pour
homicide volontaire il a été placé en
détention provisoire on le voit la
justice avant pourtant les émeutes elles
ne s'arrêtent pas peut-être avant de
vous répondre dire qu'effectivement
organiser la parole c'est fondamental
c'est et d'ailleurs c'est aussi ma
responsabilité de faire tampon d'être là
de parler avec tout le monde avec la
police avec les jeunes avec les
habitants des quartiers je salue tous
les acteurs d'ailleurs qui étaient sur
le pont aujourd'hui qui sont eux-mêmes
inquiets et donc je crois qu'il faut
reconstruire des processus démocratiques
beaucoup plus importants que ceux que
nous avons connu jusqu'à maintenant les
habitants ont eu le sentiment d'être
concerté mais que les décisions
n'allaient pas avec la concertation que
les résultats n'étaient pas n'étaient
pas là que les inégalités ont continué
de croître alors ce que peut faire le
gouvernement face à ça il peut mettre
sur la table réellement ce débat il faut
accepter qu'il y ait des violences
policières ça veut pas que toute la
police est violente mais il y a des
violences policières c'était interdit
d'en parler il y a quelques jours
aujourd'hui c'est une évidence il faut
être capable de parler de ça il faut
revenir sur la loi de 2017 il faut
travailler sur la politique de la ville
il faut travailler sur la démocratie il
y a beaucoup de sujets sur la table je
crois qu'il faut ouvrir le débat il faut
le structurer il faut que chacun y
participe et moi évidemment j'en serais
parti prenante à chaque fois que ce soit
impossible alors c'est violence qui
avait jusqu'à leur épargner la ville de
Blois ont finalement gagné les rues de
la préfecture loir-et-chérienne de
nombreux véhicules où ont en ont aussi
fait les frais les locaux de la police
municipale ont également été attaqués
car c'est là qu'arrive les images des
caméras de vidéoprotection de la ville
le point dans ce reportage avec Michael
Texier Lucas Chopin
les stigmates de la nuit de violence à
Blois sont encore bien visibles ce
vendredi matin le bureau de poste a été
pris pour cible il restera ferme et
aujourd'hui les violences ont commencé
dès la tombée de la nuit hier on voit
ici des jeunes cagoulés armés de Batz et
de bars seulement la désolation sur leur
passage la directrice de cabinet
évoquait cette nuit un groupe entre 100
et 200 individus qui auraient commencé
assez tôt dans la soirée puisque
des témoins prévus les forces de l'ordre
à préparer des cocktails Molotov et puis
assez rapidement
en tout début de soirée en fait les
événements ont commencé avec des feux de
poubelles il y a eu le scooter quelques
véhicules et puis c'est monté en
puissance tout au long de la soirée et
de la nuit
vers 23h ce sont les locaux de la police
municipale qui sont visées à l'intérieur
des fonctionnaires et le directeur de
cabinet du maire stupéfait et personnel
qui était à l'intérieur ont eu vraiment
vraiment peur et ils étaient en train de
superviser les images quand ils ont
aperçu une centaine de gens cagoulés et
en noir qui se dirigeaient vers eux ils
ont compris qu'il fallait se parler les
assaillants ont vandalisé les voitures
autour sur la rue ils ont pénétré dans
la cour
ils ont pas réussi à rentrer dans les
locaux malgré effectivement des assauts
répétés puisqu'il a fallu deux
interventions de la police nationale et
municipale pour pour mettre les
personnels qui étaient à l'intérieur en
sécurité une cellule de soutien
psychologique a été mise en place pour
les agents de la ville le maire souhaite
en faire de même pour les habitants j'ai
sollicité en effet le préfet pour la
mise en place d'une cellule de soutien
psychologique pour les habitants qui
étaient très nombreux à nous appeler à
l'hôtel de ville pour des questions mais
on sentait bien aussi une préoccupation
de l'angoisse de l'inquiétude donc c'est
le rôle de l'État de mettre en place ces
cellules de soutien au total hier 80
pompiers ont été engagés tout au long de
la nuit pour circonscrire les différents
incendies
cette idée d'une cellule d'écoute
psychologique est-ce que ce serait aussi
envisageable en Indre-et-Loire le
demande c'est un effet tout à fait c'est
ce que je disais tout à l'heure ce qu'on
a besoin aussi que les habitants se
livrent et raconte ce qu'ils ont vécu et
puis ils ont des suggestions aussi ils
ont des solutions à apporter donc moi je
suis très à l'écoute de ce que le
terrain nous dit en fait c'est ce qu'il
faut faire après sur les modalités mais
il faut voir comment s'organise mais
c'est nécessaire
ouais non juste je voulais saluer le
travail des élus locaux aussi dans ce
moment moi j'ai appelé tous les maires
ceux que j'ai pu joindre puisque
Emmanuel François a perdu ses deux
téléphones dans la situation qu'il a
vécu hier mais en tout cas j'ai pu avoir
le maire de La Riche le maire de
Joué-lès-Tours et dire aussi voilà que
chacun a une position digne en ce
moment-là sans jouer dans la surenchère
et essaie de faire face à des situations
très difficiles donc je vous salue
saluer leur leur esprit de
responsabilité je crois que c'est
ensemble que nous pourrons répondre à ce
type de crise alors les dernières
grosses émeutes en France
émeutes en France date de 2005 avec la
mort de Zied et Bouna de jeunes
électrocuté après avoir trouvé refuge
dans un poste électrique sauf qu'à
l'époque les réseaux sociaux
n'existaient pas ils n'étaient pas aussi
répandue aujourd'hui comment on fait
avec cette nouvelle donne sachant qu'il
existe des plateformes on se donne
clairement rendez-vous pour commettre
des dégradations en bande est-ce que de
votre côté à la préfecture vous vous
gérez les réseaux sociaux gérer les
réseaux sociaux et côté modéré un réseau
social c'est compliqué j'ai vu que le
Président de la République avait fait
une démarche en ce sens c'est clairement
un phénomène qui accélère et amplifie ce
qui se passe parce que même un fan de ce
qu'on voit que de surenchères
donc c'est terrible et on sait à quel
point nos jeunes sont connectés
bien plus qu'en 2005 évidemment donc
tout ça va très vite moi ce que je
constate aussi c'est que alors on a eu
des difficultés on a eu des risques
interquartiers
qui ont lieu et là aujourd'hui même les
quartiers se regroupent finalement se
retrouvent
mais bon voilà c'est aussi ce qu'on ce
qu'on constate
la question des réseaux sociaux se pose
à toutes les échelles dans notre société
elle est en accélérateur formidable pour
accéder à la Haute-Savoie aux échanges
les politiques l'utilisent beaucoup et
en même temps évidemment dans des
situations comme ça là c'est un
accélérateur pour pour s'organiser et
pour organiser ses émeutes je crois que
c'est peu contrôlable pour autant la
question de ce qui se passe sur les
réseaux sociaux forcément elle doit être
mis sur la table sur le contrôle des
écrans il y a des propositions de loi
qui ont été étudiées sur le sujet je
crois qu'il faudra travailler à ça mais
ça réglera pas les sujets de fonds c'est
dans ce moment là un moyen puis
effectivement il y a une surenchère
chacun
essaye d'exister en ayant fait pire que
l'autre et ça c'est évidemment en même
temps ces réseaux sociaux vous
permettent aussi j'allais dire
d'identifier certains criminels
à droite aussi par les autorités donc ça
nous donne on a énormément d'éléments
d'informations il faut qu'il le sache il
y aura évidemment
interpeller des personnes dans un temps
plus long évidemment il y a du bon et de
moins bon vous savez que si on avait
interdit comme la loi l'avait imaginé
comme ça avait été imaginé dans la loi
de filmer des policiers cette situation
n'aurait jamais été connue puisque
finalement les premières déclarations de
tout le monde c'était de dire légitime
défense et on a pu mesurer voilà et donc
il y a des images elles ont parfois
elles sont elles vont jouer en défaveur
parfois elles ont en faveur dans les
réseaux sociaux c'est exactement la même
chose c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
le calme va-t-il
prochaine dans le doute au centre social
pluriel implanté dans le quartier du
Sanita ça tourne on a pris quelques
précautions après avoir reçu des menaces
l'association qui œuvrent pour le mieux
vivre ensemble à préférer débarrasser
une partie de ses affaires ce vendredi
après-midi Sébastien Branger
réveil difficile dans le quartier du
Sanitas après les événements d'hier soir
ici au centre social pluriel implanté
dans le quartier depuis une dizaine
d'années on se prépare au pire via les
réseaux sociaux l'établissement a reçu
des menaces faisant craindre des
dégradations ordinateur dossier
administratif équipement de valeurs tout
était évacué pour être mis à l'abri une
première pour pluriel j'espérais qu'on
soit protégé du fait qu'on accueille les
mamans les enfants les jeunes
et jusqu'à présent c'était le cas
après faut se rendre compte que la
colère elle est énorme qui a des bords
dans tous les sens et que malgré le fait
qu'on
œuvre pour le quartier et pour les
jeunes bah voilà il y en a qui
comprennent pas forcément
[Musique]
qui qui qui ne le voit pas de la même
manière donc puis là ils attaquent
toutes les institutions donc tout le
paradoxe de ces émeutes c'est aussi de
s'en prendre aux équipements et aux
structures qui facilitent la vie dans
ses espaces urbains ou règne la misère
sociale une situation incompréhensible
pour la plupart des habitants pourquoi
s'en prendre à tous ces innocents ils
n'ont rien demandé ils n'ont rien
demandé c'est leur faire du mal
gratuitement faut penser ou pas
mais on laissait leur bout de chou leur
petit
trouver quelqu'un pour la garde et même
au Seigneur nous on a besoin de cette
association pour justement pour les
activités moi je suis adhérente si j'ai
plus cette association je fais comment
je vais devenir comment déjà que je suis
sans travail mais cette association elle
est primordiale pour moi mais
l'injustice doit se faire entendre
l'injustice on doit crier haut et fort
exceptionnellement le centre social
pluriel sera fermé jusqu'à nouvel ordre
mais le standard téléphonique restera
ouvert pour répondre aux questions des
bénéficiaires
alors Guillaume sacré qu'une
manifestation non autorisée contre les
violences policières et prévues ce
vendredi soir à Jean Jaurès à 20h à
l'heure où nous enregistrons cette CJT
il y a déjà des débordements qui
commencent dans la ville alors je peux
pas vous confirmer la
j'ai des informations sur lesquelles il
y aurait en effet des débordements dans
certains lieux mais je sais pas la
nature exactement
pour la manifestation je sais pas si
cette manifestation était à l'origine de
des armes et je crois pas c'est pas si
facile elle est elle est interdite pour
la simple raison que les portes les
forces de police sont
ultra mobilisées et que c'était inutile
de rajouter un élément de complexité moi
je partage c'était cette manifestation
alors le préfet me disait les
soulèvements de la terre ça reste à
vérifier puisque les soulèvements de la
terre ont été dissous les formes sont
extrêmement tout le monde peut s'en
revendiquer mais elle n'a pas de sens là
à cet instant elle est contre-productive
et donc voilà moi je l'ai dit je peux
soutenir un centre de revendications qui
sont portés par les soulèvements de la
terre si tantex que ça soit eux puisque
c'est très compliqué c'est des
inscriptions sur les murs qui ont dit
appelle à être devant les mairies à 20h
et s'il y a un sujet avec les violences
policières pour autant là c'est ce
serait une catastrophe et donc je
comprends que cette manifestation était
interdite ça me paraissait évidemment
absolument nécessaire tous les deux que
conseillez-vous riverains qui peuvent
être témoins de ces incendies vous
l'avez dit appeler une fois mais pas
plusieurs fois est-ce qu'il faut rester
chez soi est-ce qu'il faut essayer
d'intervenir pour éteindre des petits
incendies avant qu'ils ne deviennent
plus grands que doit-on faire vraiment
le message c'est de signaler et de ne
pas intervenir je pense qu'il faut pas
se mettre en situation de risque on voit
bien que chaque nuit est différente
session la situation extrêmement
complexe la nuit présente n'est pas la
même enfin qu'hier donc c'est vraiment
le message c'est de pas se mettre en
difficulté le message c'est garder vos
enfants
et c'est vraiment le message qu'on a
adressé aux médiateur au centre de vie
ça c'est sensibiliser les familles
est-ce que vous avez conseillé au
restaurateur au bar
de matinée peut-être pas forcément une
bonne idée ce soir non évoquait
évidemment couvre-feu pour les mineurs
qui et qui entre en vigueur on a fait
passer en effet un message de vigilance
tous les commerces
de dire ce qui est les bons de faire
évidemment rester chez soi être éloigné
ça et en même temps juste un point de
réflexion les attaques cibles des
bâtiments vides voilà et évidemment si
plus rien ne fonctionne c'est un nombre
de cibles potentiel je dis ça par
rapport aux équipements sportifs ou la
décision a été prise de de les fermer à
partir de 17 heures je m'interroge voilà
sur si tout s'arrête est-ce que
finalement ce vide là n'est pas de
nature à amplifier les tensions c'est
une réflexion j'ai pas de réponse
absolue mais en tout cas la question
méritait d'être à mon avis posée et je
crois que surtout personne n'a des
réponses seules dans une période comme
celle-là il faut que tout le monde se
concerte et moi j'en appelle à toutes
les résistance pour qu'on travaille
ensemble et qu'on réfléchisse ensemble
aux bonnes réponses merci merci à tous
d'être venu sur ce plateau avant de
conclure cette édition spéciale préparée
avec les journalistes de la rédaction je
tenais à vous signaler l'agression de
l'une des nôtres hier soir alors qu'elle
filmait place de la Liberté à tour une
collègue de Tv Tours Val de Loire à
violemment été prise à partir Emilie
avec vous on voulait revenir sur ce fait
divers oui c'est ce généraliste je suis
pas dans le rôle dans lequel
téléspectateur de la chaîne me
connaissent le plus j'interviens plus en
tant que de directrice de TV turbal de
Loire je voulais déjà vous remercier
tous de cette édition spéciale et salut
aussi le cran de l'équipe qu'il a
construite aujourd'hui je voulais au nom
de toute la rédaction de TV tourval de
Loire de tous les collègues de la chaîne
et aussi du groupe Nouvelle République
apporté le soutien à notre jeune
journaliste qui a été encerclé hier et
violemment prise à partie par une
quinzaine de personnes masquées
bousculer une journaliste casser sa
caméra déjà c'est condamnable mais
l'insulter la menacée de mort la course
et quand elle tente de prendre la fuite
ça tout simplement intolérable elle
n'est pas blessée physiquement mais elle
est très choquée et ses compréhensible
c'est pas la première fois qu'un
journaliste est ciblé en raison de son
métier pendant un reportage on sait que
ça s'est passé aussi à Nîmes au début du
mois et c'est malheureusement
probablement pas la dernière fois alors
je voudrais juste faire un rappel
attaquer un ou une journée liste c'est
attaqué à la fois la liberté de la
presse et puis aussi le droit à
l'information et évidemment une plainte
va être déposée merci merci évidemment
oui nous pensons tout ça elle voilà
c'est la fin de cette édition spéciale
consacrée aux violences urbaines qui ont
lieu la nuit dernière merci à vous de
l'avoir suivie je vous souhaite à tous
un très bon weekend et je l'espère le
plus calme possible
[Musique]